[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de medio ambiente
de france 24 soy maría clara calle y hoy
hablaremos del plástico porque el club
de los países más ricos publicó su
primer informe sobre el ciclo de vida
del plástico en todo el mundo la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico la ocde encontró
que la producción anual de este producto
se duplicó en los últimos 20 años al
igual que sus desperdicios de los cuales
el 40% proviene de plástico usado para
empaques uno de los hallazgos más
preocupantes es que sólo el 9 por ciento
del plástico mundial se recicla mientras
que el 19 por ciento es incinerado el
resto va a vertederos ilegales o
controlados el resultado es una huella
de carbono significativa solamente del
plástico fue responsable del 3,4 por
ciento de las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero en 2019 según la
ocede el organismo apunta a que uno de
los mayores problemas es que las
políticas para regular este mercado son
fragmentadas
aunque 120 países prohíben el plástico
de un solo uso la mayoría sólo pone este
límite para las bolsas
algo efectivo para reducir la basura
pero que no restringe el consumo de este
producto por eso la ocde hizo un llamado
a encontrar soluciones coordinadas y
globales a pocos días de que la onu
discuta en la asamblea de medio ambiente
si abrieron las puertas para un tratado
internacional que limite la
contaminación por plásticos y mientras
uno se enfrenta a la causa de la crisis
climática otros padecen los eventos
extremos en la última semana naciones
europeas como inglaterra países bajos
irlanda o bélgica sufrieron con el paso
de la tormenta y un is que tuvo una
particularidad pocas veces antes vista
mientras que en el sur de américa los
tiempos secos provocaron uno de los
peores incendios forestales en la
historia de argentina y están golpeando
a la agricultura en paraguay hagamos un
repaso en el siguiente informe
casas hospitales y carreteras destruidas
se deja el paso de la tormenta yunís por
el norte de europa
los vientos fueron tan fuertes que reinó
unido- declaró alerta roja en el sur de
inglaterra e incluso en londres la
advertencia implicaba un riesgo
significativo para la vida y ráfagas por
encima de los 150 kilómetros por hora
el servicio metereológico nacional de
reino unido e incluso señaló que ésta
podía ser una de las tormentas más
dañinas de los últimos años
yunís tiene una particularidad todavía
más peligrosa el chorro del aguijón que
es una nube en forma de cola de
escorpión donde el viento tiene mucha
más velocidad y
es muy inusual que ocurra un chorro de
aguijón lo que producen los vientos
realmente fuertes en la superficie y
desde una perspectiva meteorológica
estoy segura de que estudiaremos este
caso en muchos de nuestros artículos
cursos de capacitación para quienes
serán meteorólogos y cada vez las
tormentas podrían empeorar por el
calentamiento global modelos climáticos
de la universidad de newcastle y la
oficina meteorológica británica han
demostrado que a medida que la
temperatura aumenta hay más aire
caliente con más humedad en consecuencia
la lluvia se intensifica
y no es la única cara de crisis
climática en argentina el tiempo seco ha
contribuido a uno de los peores
incendios forestales en la historia del
país cerca del 9% del territorio de la
provincia de corrientes se quemó lo que
es más de 780 mil hectáreas a mediados
de febrero las llamas avanzaban tan
rápido que consumían 30.000 hectáreas en
un solo día esto es algo similar a toda
la superficie de la república de malta
de lo que nos toca vivir este año
unos años atrás queda que el cambio
climático ha generado estos incendios de
gran magnitud muy difícil de controlar
en el mundo no estamos solamente en
argentina la sequía en la vecina
paraguay es tan grave que los
productores de soja estiman que dejarían
de producir hasta un 60% por la falta de
lluvia y aunque la ciencia todavía no
comprueba que los eventos son cada vez
más extremos por el calentamiento global
lo cierto es que cada vez se ven más
catástrofes climáticas
y las catástrofes climáticas no están
pasando únicamente en este momento sino
también se trata de las que podrían
venir los arrecifes de coral en todas
las regiones del mundo están amenazados
por el cambio climático esa es la
afirmación con la que comienza un
reciente estudio publicado en la revista
plos climate sobre estos ecosistemas una
de las más grandes amenazas para los
corales son las llamadas olas de calor
marinas que son periodos en los que la
temperatura del mar aumenta
drásticamente cuando los corales
soportan calor durante un largo tiempo
pueden decolorarse pues pierden las
algas que viven dentro de su tejido y
esas algas son su principal fuente de
alimento el estudio apunta que el 84 por
ciento de los arrecifes están ubicados
en los llamados refugios térmicos que es
donde viven protegidas grandes colonias
de corales pero si la temperatura de la
tierra aumenta 15 grados celsius
podríamos quedar solo con el 0,2 por
ciento de esos refugios y si la
temperatura sube 2 grados en relación
con los niveles preindustriales se
acabarían los refugios corales en todo
el mundo según la investigación
fusión sería enorme pues en los
arrecifes vive una cuarta parte de toda
la vida marina y medio billón de
personas se alimenta y vive de los que
pescan allí además tardarían al menos
una década estos corales para
recuperarse de la extensa mortandad así
llegamos al final de nuestro programa
pueden ver esta y todas nuestras
emisiones en nuestro canal de youtube y
consultar más información en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]